bang-bang I have a special treat for you
today mr. robert kiyosaki himself I
think the best seller ever when it comes
to personal finance many of you if I
read Rich Dad Poor Dad I have so well
thanks so much for taking the time to do
this Robert I'm honored I was just
saying how much I've enjoyed their
guests because I learn a lot if you talk
to Caitlyn long tell her except for that
lousy power outages from Wyoming it
would've been a great program but she
was fantastic and I said your fiancee is
still my favorite I will make sure they
both know so you don't know this story
but in 2008 I was 20 years old in Iraq
on a deployment in the US military and I
read Rich Dad Poor Dad for the first
time and I read it along with two other
books richest man in Babylon and
thinking Grow Rich and I always tell
people that those three books kind of
being read simultaneous at that point my
life changed my mindset when it came to
finance money work etc and you wrote the
book know what 23 24 years ago so first
of all just give us an update on kind of
the book itself and kind of the impact
has had well thank you for lumping me
together with those books man those
those are classics I mean I wrote myself
your trust me Rich Dad Poor Dad two
classic at this point to whether you
want to admit it or not I can't believe
it because it is number one in the world
so far you know you know there was those
books that you told me about that you
read I read changed my life too yeah but
for me to think that I I would write a
classic you know that's classic you know
cuz I flunked out of school so I can't
write so I flunked my sophomore year and
I flunked my senior year because the
teacher my English teacher says you
can't write and but the fact was I
couldn't spell that's why they have a
spell checker these days I know and I
tried this one on the teeth one wasn't
male one was a female and I said well
it's a very uncreated person who can't
spell a word three
four different ways I love it
well here's all I wanted to talk to you
on the podcast today is you have done
two things that I think are really
important one is obviously you've been
teaching people for 20-plus years on
personal educate or personal finance a
lot of things that schools don't teach
and kind of this idea that savers or
losers and not put your money to work
but also recently you started to really
warn people
hey there is the likelihood that we are
going to see a market downturn and kind
of how people can protect themselves
both of those things end up being pretty
valuable in the world that we're
existing in today so maybe just start
with like what's your view of where we
are in the global economy right well
what's going on right now from kind of
your perspective well obviously we're
going for ended up a depression right
now I mean this pandemic I know it's
real but I smell a rat if you know what
I mean
and there's a lot of you know a lot of
people have been warning I've been
warning it's coming I've been you know
what most people don't listen you know
the next book I'm writing is with Jim
Rickards he's you know road to ruin and
currency wars we've been warning people
for years and the book were going to
write together is called Ravens and a
raven was a bird of Greek mythology that
could see the future but also and so if
you if you ever saw me back in 2008 I
was on wolf Blitzer's program
in January saying Lehman Brothers was
going to come down oh let's Lee goes and
que pasa you can't say that my
advertisers will cancel us it's gonna
come down you know and he balked and
then they had an agent of Wall Street on
the program with me and she attacked me
and I just shined it on you know but I'm
not an agent for Wall Street I'm not you
know there were criminal elements Sam
was the Fed so that's kind of why I
called it and then was September 2008
Lehman went down the Dow dropped from 14
to zero I hope you know and and I made
so much freakin money because you make
more money in a crash than you do in a
boom you know but anyway people don't
listen and as there's enough not only
does it Raven as a prophet spirit of
prophecy a Cassandra he's also from a
bleed Greek mythology and a cassandra is
a woman who was born with the gift of
seeing the future except that nobody
believed her and I think that's really
the problem you know and I know that
you're a Bitcoin fanatic I have a few
but the reason I endorse Bitcoin is just
for one freaking reason you're not part
of the system
you know III quote you all the time it's
a separation a government and my money
and you know what I say to people what
do you know you're an old guy so yeah
I'm very old
I'm coronavirus number one target you
know I've had pneumonia three times and
said they're after me but so is Wall
Street you know the next guys are gonna
get toasted are the baby boomers in
their pensions their pensions are empty
you know they look it's a promise no
it's not a promise you know it's
[ __ ] yeah one of the things I think
that's really important here and you
kind of hit on a couple of these so
first is the system is working as
designed and I think a lot of people
missed that point right so it's not that
the system is cortical broken it's that
the system no longer serves majority of
the people and I think once people kind
of realized the system is working as is
designed that highlights part of the
issue but let's start first with the
pension problem I know you're super
passionate about this I have no more
banging of the drum to do so maybe you
can get through to people but help us
understand what exactly is the issue
with the pensions and then kind of what
do you think plays out over the next you
know 12 to 36 months and it with the
pensions well you know as you've said
and I've said and everybody said you
know the best teachers stay on YouTube
they're not in our universities
universe is a bunch of criminals you
know I mean as far as I don't like my
poor dad and I rich that imported
they're all poured as phd's PhD sends
for poor helpless and desperate
desperate people and the only thing a
schoolteacher cares about his tenure
your enemy and because there's another
guy Jordan Peterson Ellison CDC he says
it really well he says you know these
professors because he's a professor also
and he says the reason they need ten
years because I need to be protected so
they they sell to the kids you've you're
you're uh you're weak you're fragile you
know you've got to be protected the
government's gonna you know you got you
gotta protect you from the rich and so
that's when these kids are coming out of
school you know I was a Marine and thank
you for serving on the army but I was a
marine and and a lot of those guys that
spit on me when I came back from Vietnam
I went there twice
are today the college professors you
know what you're not just communists
pinkos so I I don't really have much
affection for college professors they're
good people
you gotta go to college gonna become a
doctor a lawyer an attorney or whatever
it is you know account but they're not
the bravest people on earth they're
cowards you know those are the guys
that's spit on me they're the hippies of
my generation and the you know the
accuse me of being a baby killer and all
that stuff and so you know like when I
go to the Vietnam Wall I want to cry you
know because my friends died to get spit
on and now they're leaving an academic
system and they're sending out these
kids who are fragile you know Nassim
Taleb calls there's three kinds of
people there's fragile robust and anti
fragile mm-hmm and when I was telling my
friends with boys as specialists and you
know your boys are wimps you know the
their Mama's boys they goes oh ho don't
say that I said you know they can't find
a job so they're living at home you know
they're wimps
don't say that but they went to school
they're fragile as hell you can't say
who you hurt their feelings you know I
mean pop the the sergeant never hurts
your feelings every day and I used to
shut my mouth and do what he said and if
if somebody wasn't hurting my feelings
well I mean here's a great example of it
right I said actually this morning I
tweeted something that I said fortune
500 CEOs that are like begging for these
bailouts all I'm hearing is they're
basically quitting right there saying
hey this problems too big and I can't
figure it out and the comparison in my
mind is you have small business owners
that their businesses are being
decimated but they're figuring out how
to survive so hey we were my favorite
example is on the group that was setting
up the stages for Coachella right the
big music festival they're supposed to
do all of the kind of logistics and that
all of a sudden realized Coachella's
cancelled so there goes majority of our
revenue for the year they immediately
pivoted and they've been building FEMA
tents for health care services and
health care workers is that's a small
business owner who says look if I don't
make a decision here and change my
business and adapt we will die this
business will go under all to fire all
my employees etc that to me is somebody
who's on offense who's kind of taking
responsibility for what they've signed
up for etc the opposite end of that is a
lot of corporate CEOs here said hey I
can't figure out the problem it's too
big of a problem so half the government
come save me and to me it's like
employees should stand up and say hey
well if you can't solve the problem why
don't you leave and let's go find a CEO
who can solve the problem because the
problem has to be solved and interest I
don't know I I just don't get it but
maybe you and I just have a different
view of the world I guess no I mean I
that's what I see the corporate CEOs
like I I grew I grew up just an Steve
Burke of NBC Universal they're all
hitting the ripcord been there they're
airborne right the smart ones got out
there pulling that d-ring man they're
getting out now you know so they you
know they've corporate credit you know
they're basically
taken triple-a corporation's dropped
them to [ __ ] be next stop is junk and
those are CEOs at Ford Motor Company
AT&T GE IBM they've ripped off not only
you and I they ripped off the pensions
they ripped off their shareholders and
they've ripped off their employees
they're bad leaders you know and that's
why I often say that most of the people
who are leading the country are like my
poor dead you know what was that guy he
was talking to oh Jesus Cameron raising
anyway he talks about two kinds of
leaders
there's no time CEO and peacetime CEO
Ben Horowitz war here war leaders and
peacetime heroes leaders and most of our
leaders are peacetime I call them
peacetime [ __ ] yeah I mean I just
really have no use
I don't think good people I'm sure in
all this but how can you screw your own
people that's against the code it's
against the code you know it's a
military school although I had bad
grades up high us 80s and I got accepted
to Naval Academy and Marine Academy took
Merchant Marine Academy because my
highest paid graduates of the world and
when I graduated four years later I was
being paid like my classmates in 69
making a hundred twenty thousand ka year
tax-free
but back then it was a lot of money and
the Vietnam War was still wrong this
isn't 69 and like a [ __ ] idiot I went
down to this I went down to this
recruitment station and there was a guy
from the Army Navy Air Force in a Marine
Corps and all the other stuff and so the
Coast Guard stands up there they say
we're here to save people's lives and
the Navy says we sail ships what are
they talk about the army says we have
the best vehicles in town the biggest
motor pool the Air Force say they're the
best golf courses and then the Marine
stands up misses like boys and girls
there's only one reason you want to be a
Marine we kill people if you want to
save people's lives
join the [ __ ] Coast Guard even when I
killed people join the Marine Corps for
some reason I'm standing in front well
sounds like fun you know so I came up
that $120,000 a year a job to make 200 a
month as a lieutenant on my way to
flight school in Pensacola on to Camp
Pendleton on to Okinawa and into Vietnam
you know and when I came back when I
came out of country and went back to
Okinawa I was a changed man and that's
what's really hard to tell people you
know joining the military is one thing
but being in combats another when I came
back to Okinawa where the Marine Marine
base is and was was it is I thought my
fellow Marines were [ __ ] you know
there was a supply guys in the rear but
the gear and the beer you know I mean
why'd I go supply but I had changed so
much just you know I'm going to be up
now I'm twice but each time I came back
it was transformational so I really have
a hard time talking to somebody if they
didn't serve in combat if there are a
supply guy or something but even worse
than that is somebody who never served
in the military you know I just don't
understand it
I think part of what you're highlighting
here is there's a mindset right now I
heard you on a recent interview you
basically said look this whole crisis is
in your head right and I thought that
was a really illuminating statement and
really because what it does is it is the
way you react to the crisis right the
crisis is gonna happen whether you like
it or not we all don't want it to happen
but it's happening in the crisis being
in your head essentially the way I heard
it was you can either let it happen to
you and you be the receiver of all of
that pain or you can be responsible and
have personal responsibility and
basically say look I got a navigate this
correctly and if you're really good
now will you navigate it successfully
but you'll actually come out the other
side stronger wealthier better
positioned then you went into it
but it all comes from that mindset of am
I gonna let the world happen to me or am
I gonna kind of implement my will on the
world that's the curse right right I
mean if you're not doing well if you're
not thriving today in this crisis then
someone to your head
somebody crawled upside your butt and
into your head and messed with it
you know go to school get a job or card
taxes save money and get out of debt and
an investable long term in a
well-diversified portfolio stocks bonds
mutual funds and ETFs if you've done
that you're in big trouble so as you
know if you don't change your thoughts
you don't change your life and that's
why I've been you know I've been
tweeting on I know I'm so old I don't
know what Twitter is but anyway what was
the talk oh I said but our YouTube man
there's some the best teachers all right
- and they're not getting paid
stupid academic rates you know they
don't have tenure most of them if
they're a real teacher they're doing
really well today you're doing well I'm
doing well I would listen to us not that
phone Ian at Harvard you know the piece
time leader yeah but I think that this
also like what you're highlighting you
know and again you've said it before is
like the dying of the Industrial Age and
and really the acceleration of a shift
to information age maybe explain that a
little bit what do you mean when you say
the Industrial Age is ending and we're
now really getting thrust into that
Information Age look at what we're doing
today you know I mean you know
Industrial Age when when it would change
from agrarian to industrial the horse
saw the car doing I mean the horse could
see the car and I said oh my job was
done and the horse was finished that's
up for racing but today you can't see
the change so one way so in 1989 when
the world wide web came up and the
Berlin Wall came down
simultaneous that thought that was
interesting you know so that was it's
another transformation it's no different
than when you know let's say I'm a king
I'm a king and Portugal or something and
I got all my archers on my sword
guys in my spirit guys and some
entrepreneur drives up there with his
cannon he doesn't load that Canada and
blows the guy's walls down you know but
that's kind of what's happening today
you know all the old guys standing in
their castle walls and some
entrepreneurs senator pound the crap out
of them
so exactly when I was with Steve Burke
of nbc/universal he was saying the guys
what we're doing the guys on social
media are kicking their butts right now
they don't know what to do
you know they can't stop us so that's
kind of what I'm talking about the
problem is the average person because
they went to school looking for a job
they can't see what's going on they're
blind so you know like and I think was
on your program you hold up a cell phone
you got more power in that cell phone
then when I first went to the Academy in
New York in 65 they had full you know
rooms blown Sperry computers and all
that you got more power in that cell
phone than that Sperry computer at my
school in New York and if you can't make
money with that cell phone hang up the
jockstrap man you don't have it yeah and
I think that part of this is the models
don't change just the execution does
right the difference between kind of
old-school NBC live television to what
we're doing now to the kid who's posting
a tick-tock you know six second video
it's all just a guy uh rich greenfield
came on he said it's a war for attention
here's everyone talks about streaming
wars or movie wars or TV wars he goes
it's all the same it's just there's 24
hours in a day somebody's gonna sleep
about eight hours of those so you got 16
hours left and we're all competing for
the same hours and how do you entertain
or inform somebody over everyone else it
Altima comes down to value and I think
to your point more and more people are
finding the value outside of those
traditional means because they just
think that it actually has a bigger
impact well if I could go back to
something more basic than that what's
not what I was sorry talking about the
start of this whole thing is act like I
told my my friend I said you know
your son is a web it nice to have joined
the Marine Corps
join the [ __ ] army do [ __ ]
something you know grow up just grow up
if you're hiding out sucking your thumb
with mommy and daddy there's something
really wrong with you Jeremy there was
something there's something lacking in
your character of course this is a
couple of years this is when does a
storm first kick in you know and the Sun
never went in the Marine Corps because
his mother was afraid he might die he
might live - I said no he'd probably be
a supply guy in the rear with the gear
and the beer but Lucy goes through basic
training you know but they don't get it
and then and that's the thing between
wartime leader and peacetime leader
most people are peacetime [ __ ]
they're so afraid today and there's more
opportunity as you and I know than ever
before the history of the world and it's
it's in your hand it's called the iPhone
or Android already guys call those damn
things but you can't think cause you're
so afraid yeah that's the problem so one
of the things that you've done a
fantastic job I think teaching people
over the years is how money in the
economy works right everything from the
cash flow quadrant of just get the hell
out of the left side and get on the
right side of the thing et cetera you've
literally educated millions of people
for those that don't understand it the
stimulus I think is there's two
components to it that crack me up right
and I want European so the first is the
$1,200 check I just call that that's the
bribe that's the bribe for social to
avoid social unrest now we're gonna give
you guys 1,200 bucks everybody shut up
and you know we're trying to help you
and if things get really bad we
basically give you $1,200 and you're
good which isn't actually helpful to
majority of people right but then you
also get the stimulus to the
corporations which you know you've
highlighted it's just socialism for
corporations or socialism for the rich
so maybe talk a little bit about what
exactly you mean by socialism for
corporations or for the rich well I
think this is a great book it's a pig
but you know get the book is called the
creature from Jekyll Island by my friend
Tierra Griffith and this is I think it's
a 1996 book came out and he wrote in
there bailout is the name of the game so
the feds only purpose and the Fed is not
a bank
it's a cartel owned by the richest
people in the planet which will never
see their and their this guy Gretch this
is what NASA for Grunch stands for gross
Universal cash lights so the guys at all
the feared control the world not the fit
but they control the world so once you
understand that to go okay now I'd
better start doing something different
so what the Fed what the the creature
does it drops the world into this crisis
and a pendant pendant the pandemic is
probably real but then you get so
desperate you'll take the money
it's communism yeah see what happens
what Edward Griffin says in a creature
from Jekyll Island was that when Marx
attempted to bring communism to America
the problem was Americans are too tough
the American spirit is too strong so
what Griffin is saying here what the
what whoever what fuller calls grudge
had to do or Marx had to do was
introduce socialism first so the way you
introduce socialism is called Social
Security and all that the happiest
crisises the depression you know 9/11
this one over here and people get so
desperate rickards are saying the same
thing you know a road to Rouen and all
that we get so desperate we'll take
anything and so they're gonna give you
this thousand dollar check to but first
have to bust your spirit and that's what
I was saying to my friend you know send
your kid even to the Coast Guard let me
do something you know grow up so you get
so just but you take that check next
stop is communism
so he goes capitalism socialism
communism and you can see it right now
because they're gonna bail Boeing out
guess what the feds gonna take Clark
ownership a Boeing that's communism
you'll study economics idiots up there I
mean that's communism so it they bust
our spirits oh $1,200 the government cuz
I don't have a job well that's the
that's the same exact number that did in
Hong Kong not too long ago you know
those guys are rioting in the streets
they gave $1,200 also and the branch by
Bucky fuller gross Universal Cash ice
beams VR money all systems that's why
there's no financial education in
schools and that's why today I'm doing
better than ever I'm making money hand
over fist you know my biggest problems
they can't get enough inventory my cash
flow game it's a good problem not
complaining but we have to pay extra air
freight I'm in know it stuff like this
stuff that's a good problem but we were
prepared for it yeah the witness he went
to school you're not yeah I think part
of what you're really highlighting here
is this whole idea that anytime a crisis
occurs it's an opportunity to grab civil
liberties personal freedom and also
economically and the part to me that I
don't understand why people are missing
this but I think you've done a great job
highlighting it is the socialism for the
rich and the corporations that's gonna
happen whether you and I like it or not
it's gonna happen and so that's just you
know what it is
but the cost for the bottom 50% of
Americans when they when the stimulus
occurs right that the devaluation of the
currency and kind of all of the things
that I think the gold bugs and and the
bit corners have been yelling and
screaming about for years
it's here it's happening right before
our eyes and the sad part is that the
people who get hurt the most are the
people who are the most vulnerable right
the people who actually need the most
help they get hurt because they're
sitting in cash they have no real assets
they're getting paid you know hourly
wages that aren't adjusted for inflation
etc and there's nothing they can really
do other than educate themselves which
is what you spent the last you know
twenty-something plus years doing for
people I think
well look at the worst part about it too
they send their kids to college was a
universities and they loaded up the
student loan debt and that that occurred
in 2009 you know when Obama took he
basically said to the banks look you
lend these kids all this money and the
Fed meant what the treasurer will back
him up and now those kids are desperate
that's why that's why I wrote Rich Dad
Poor Dad back in 97 I created my cash
flow board game it says our schools
don't teach us anything about money but
that's what this book was hearing grunge
was giant it's not an accident grunts
hands for gross Universal cash eyes and
we can see it today that's what this
book is saying we're shifting from
capitalism to socialism yeah Bernie
Sanders and aoc and the rest of those
cartoons running and then when they
bailout Boeing which is in trouble
anyway but they're going to take a
percentage ownership so yeah it goes
some capitalism socialism communism and
that's what this guy was saying that's
what creature from saying and that's
what rickards is saying and the road to
ruin this is not a mistake and we've
been warning people all these years and
they still send their kids to college
and learn nothing about money but they
learned that fragile you know you know
this you gotta be politically correct
politically correct is the first step of
communism it's called the freedom of
speech if I have to worry about hurting
your worthless little feeling I mean
I'll never go anywhere you know you know
what there's 72 gender pronouns now you
know in the Marine Corps there's only
two he or she that's it you know and if
you're not in here is she you don't
belong in the ring okay I'll get you but
today is like 72 gender pronouns I don't
even know what they are but so not only
if you have to worry about not knowing
your name I have no agenda pronoun you
know because you're so afraid having
your feelings hurt what do you think so
let's kind of think of we know what the
problems
right you've been highlighting it
there's a bunch of people who are
highlighting all the economic issues
that are happening right now what is the
solution and what I want to start with
is let's go macro first in terms of if
you're the president if you're the head
of the Federal Reserve etc how do you
solve the problem or turn it around and
then we'll go to the actual individual
but what do you think the solutions
really are here or are there none well I
think that's a great book written years
ago the 50s was called Atlas Shrugged by
Ayn Rand as guys like you and me we're
going into hiding the capitalists go
into hiding as socialists and communists
take over the government so I have
several hiding places right now
you know I can't tell you because I have
to kill the if I tell you where but I've
been I've been hiding for years you know
I just write these books and all this
you know my money isn't anywhere you
know and it's the same old thing so
you've got to find your friends I have
my Rich Dad advisers man I trust these
guys with my life and their women too
you know so that was the best thing I
got in the Marine Corps when we strapped
in you I was a gunship pilot when we
strapped in we were the Band of Brothers
it was a lieutenant and Sergeant and
corporal I know that we were just
brothers man we were going in to do a
very very dangerous job I went down
three times and I wouldn't be here today
without my brothers you know what I mean
and I come back I come back I land at
Norton Air Force Base in California
these hippie starts spitting on me you
know I should have shot you guys I have
an attitude problem Bob and so I'd
rather hang out with you than some
pooling correct person well I don't know
what his real gender is or her real
gender is you know I mean I don't really
care what your gender you want to you
want to jump on other boys have a good
life you know I don't want to do that I
like women but if you want to [ __ ] and
all that stuff that's up to you I don't
really care but you can upset that I
don't respect your
sexual choices why should I care it's
not my business so I think one of this
transgender stuff is spreading hate and
anger and frustration at me you know I'm
very happy liking women you know so
anyway I don't understand what's going
on in our society that's why I think the
solution is choose your friends
carefully get your Band of Brothers
choose your teachers wisely on YouTube
but you got to be careful what you put
in your head and who's got your back
that's number one who got your back and
like I said your fiance is gorgeous my
wife is gorgeous and all that they're
beautiful and they're smart and they're
you know they're they like they like
what they do
whereas some of my friends have wives
that are I'm not sure what gender they
are I just think it's kind of funny you
know I always say the the biggest lie
ever told is they lived happily ever
after
so what do you what do you think is the
economic solution though right so like
what can the Federal Reserve do or the
US government how do we stop this that's
that's what this book is saying the
creature from Jekyll Island the name of
the game is bailout their job isn't you
know inflation in this secure economy
whatever they say it is their job is to
protect the rich so they're gonna
bailout you know so they bailed out the
biggest corporations they built they're
bailing out the shadow banking system
right you know all this you know that
they're bailing out the commercial paper
market right now the big crash is in the
shadow banking system and corporate
credit and those CEOs who are
parachuting out right now they ripped
everybody else borrowing the companies
might look like Ford's money they bought
back their shares they parachute out
with stock options and they pay less
taxes they pay capital gains versus
ordinary income you know that I know
that but that we have what we have a
zombie company called a TNT
you know IBM
generally electric there used to be
Triple A the triple B now our CEOs are
criminals what they've done to our
companies but they're the best and the
brightest from our school system as it's
those peacetime leaders they ripped us
off and so is the Fed ripping us off and
so is our government rippin off Wall
Street the reason our pensions are broke
is because they stuffed our pensions
full of these toxic assets you know
what's the number-one export of America
toxic assets we ship them all over the
world Australia is going to die because
they bought our CD asses at cielos mbss
they bought all of my toxic assets all
over the world simultaneous and people
go oh I have a college degree what's a
college degree in science yeah one of my
favorite things that you've ever said is
that the great live the Federal Reserve
is that it's not a bank it's not federal
and there's no reserves it's kind of the
triple the trifecta if you will of just
the three things that people think it is
none of those three things are actually
true and the rustics a cartel like the
midian cartel the cocaine dealers well
they're not much different they're
highly educated people like my poor debt
PhDs poor helpless and desperate and
they'll do anything for that paycheck
and that's what's running our country
our world in all this it's just tragic
and it all starts with education system
what the schoolteacher about money so
the school systems part of Grudge gross
Universal cash ice buckminster fuller
that's why there's no financial
education and that's the problem and
that's what records are saying in this
book the road to ruin he talks about
don't let a good crisis go to waste
because that's what the fascists stepped
in and a fascists say oh we have this
thing called a corona virus you must
have social distancing you must wear a
mask you know you can't touch you can't
bet on what you can do you know I just
love Trump he gets up there he goes
yeah you should wear a mask but I'm not
going to that's it I like that guy screw
you I just had a Tim Kennedy who's a
Ranger qualified Special Forces sniper
come on the podcast and one of the
things that he talked about was this
whole idea of there's a number of states
now that are saying Robert if you're
from New York
you can't come to Rhode Island if you
come to Rhode Island we're gonna pull
you over and if a neighbor knows that
you came from New York we're gonna come
to your house and question you and all
this stuff and Tim put it great he goes
you know what they should do if you're
from New York they should take the New
York Yankee sign and they should stitch
it into your shirt actually don't even
use a New York Yankee sign why don't we
just start with a star right and you
very quickly can see where are we going
what is happening here and to your point
when people are suffering and people are
desperate they'll take any violation of
their rights their civil liberties etc
in exchange for that economic kind of
safety net which is what we're seeing
occur right now well that's what my rich
dad always says you know those two kinds
of people in the world wimps and pimps a
whip stands for where is my paycheck sir
and a pimp is put it in my pocket sugar
you know so you know like my my friend
says you know I'm gonna I'm gonna get a
huge check because I have employees
they're gonna give me a huge check are
you gonna take the money I said of
course what are you gonna do with it buy
more my buy more gold silver and Bitcoin
I don't need the money but I'm gonna
take it anyway yes but that's not fair I
said well that's fair to me you mean I
can't change the government but I can
change me I can protect my team I can
protect my employees my employees are
our flesh they have very high-paying
jobs I show them I show my cash status
they know we can pay them well so when
the government offered on all three and
fifty billion whatever they did the
other day I took it I just had my CFO
fill out the forms we're gonna take the
money I'm just gonna reinvest it I
haven't been watching my tweets that's
all let's say take the money buy gold
silver and Bitcoin
don't be stupid right now yes so let's
switch the individual right you've got a
a mil millions and millions of people in
the United States and they're now saying
okay here's where we are I wasn't
paying attention I didn't heed the
warnings I'm now sitting facing what is
a minimum of financial crisis if not a
depression I most likely still have a
job but that is in question moving
forward what do I do and I think that's
the number one question people want to
hear from you is just what do you do if
you're an individual today in order to
weather the storm and also put yourself
in a better position for that financial
freedom in the future given the macro
environment for it well I think people
should you know watch your your last
videos with Ron Paul and who was the
woman I guess she was in season one oh
she's fantastic
hello I love smart beautiful women you
know I just love I like pretty stupid
women too
that's not like you know smart women -
in other words the best teachers are on
YouTube wake up they're not in colleges
anymore the university system is corrupt
they sold out they're taking all of the
student loan money ripping off our
country ripping off the kids and all
this stuff and they're not teaching me I
think that's useful you know most of
these college kids coming out I can't
hire them in fact it's almost a
detriment to say you have a college
degree around my company do I mean
because what do you know was a while ago
I would Bachelor of Science they're
gonna go that's ten four BS that's like
PhD is poor helpless and desperate I
can't hire these guys you know I'm
talking about yeah talking about they're
a bunch of wimps where's my picture I
want my benefits no I don't think so
I think we're on the wrong team yeah so
when you look out and you say okay these
people gotta get educated so step one
get on YouTube get on these platforms
learn from those who are creating all
this content that's kind of step one
step two then is you've always said for
a while now real estate gold silver etc
but I'll consider kind of traditional
inflation hedge type assets what's your
view on those assets right now so forget
Bitcoin for a second just got the more
traditional real estate gold and silver
well first of all real estate gold let
me go this way it's real estate I'm
as gold silver and Bitcoin the reason is
you're off the central banking system or
outside the system you know you say it's
the separation of money and government
and that's why I say gold and silver are
God's money and bitcoin is open source
people's money I don't know much beyond
that but I'd rather have that than the
dollar I don't have to mess around with
a dollar because they're correct but
most important this is your greatest
asset your brain or is the greatest
liability and if you're in trouble today
then a liability is between your left
cheek and your right ear because you
absolutely drank some kool-aid along the
way you know you thought you were doing
the right thing like go to school get a
job pay taxes work hard safe when I get
on a debt I don't see any of that stuff
you know like real estates for two
reasons death and taxes my banker will
give me all the money I want to buy good
real estate and that with this crash
coming up again there's gonna be a lot
of good real estate coming up it's not
getting commercial but it's gonna be a
lot of good real estate coming up and I
pay less taxes if I have a lot of real
sign I pay no taxes so it's debt in
taxes that's the main reason now people
say well aren't you afraid because the
markets are crash your tenants aren't
gonna pay your rent I said I understand
that but the government will bail me out
that's called social you know it's
called anyway it's it's basically
bailing out and you know pom I'm so and
I can tell you okay anyway where was I
so you've got to know the game
understand the game I'm gonna get
build-up no matter what I do and that's
why this book here a creature from
Jekyll Island 1990 bail out there's a
name of the game they'll always bail out
the rich mm-hmm and so I get I guess
really what it is interesting about kind
of your review
the world now right is the real estate
you're using as an advantage when it
comes to the taxes and debt and you're
able to build you know quite a nice real
estate portfolio and build a real nice
business there you've got the financial
education component whether it's the
radio show the books that the board game
except you've built a great business
there and then it sounds like you're
doing at least is gold silver and
Bitcoin as a way to then take portions
of your wealth and get out of the system
right kind of escape into these non
central bank currencies or stores of
value
what changed Freaks I think early on
Bitcoin you weren't as excited and now I
think you've said hey wait a second this
is outside the system actually really
like this was there one or two
conversations or anything that you read
or anything that kind of changed your
mind and really kind of opened your eyes
to it yeah it's called the price went up
look I just say this much all right
I don't invest in things I don't
understand in my lifetime I've started a
gold mine in China big mistake they took
it okay so I understand the Chinese
meant that CCP a Chinese Communist Party
I started a silver mine in Argentina
they took that also because the company
the country is going broke and I've
started oil companies so I've done IPL's
I've done all that stuff so I understand
call silver oil so the reason I did
invest in Bitcoin
there's a million some deals deal flow
all the time I just didn't know what it
was but my friend who's he's in the
Marine Corps with me I mean he bought a
million Bitcoin and he was already
freaking rich now he looks like God so I
kind of saw the light if you don't at me
but I just have a kind of a personal
rule I don't invest unless I understand
it unless I study it and you can ask my
assistant I don't you know how to use my
cell phone so this is what I say to all
the young people if you're under 50 you
should look at Bitcoin because you might
be some some degree of tech savvy
I have not okay my career in gold and
silver started in 1972 I was flying in
Vietnam off a carrier and I'm looking at
this chart I looking at the news on my
wrist my wrist had sent me a letter and
he says hey watch out Nixon took the
dollar off the gold standard so it's
like six months earlier I said what does
that mean he says just watch the price
of gold and the world's gonna change
watch it watch it watch but then it took
six months for the frickin letter to get
to me on this carrier that's how slow it
was so then my co-pilot and I said well
let's look with some gold and so we're
looking at the map of Vietnam okay
there's like you know on the map has a
pick and a shovel or something you know
says a you gold gold mine okay
Marines aren't the brightest you know
you know show us pictures we don't get
too much so we take off and we go we're
flying along says hey we forgot
something I said what's that
the NVA over ran the gold mine
I said you mean the gold mines in enemy
hands a guy goes yeah so we're flying
looks like this with typical Marines
that's okay let's go get it anyway we
flew behind enemy lines to go look at
this gold mine
so we land in this village and the
Vietnamese I'm walking down the road and
we left our guns we took all our guns
off and all this we parked the
helicopter in this rice paddy or this
platform and we walked with the village
and we're good hey arm you know we're
here come in peace we come with dollars
you know want to buy some gold so we go
up to this gold vendor at the end of the
village and wish today I'm looking at
gold you know I look at him and he goes
how do you how do we know if it's gold
he says I don't know I thought you knew
what gold look like I said no I thought
you did no typical dumb [ __ ] Marines
we've got into an argument because we
hit gold look like because up until 1974
it was illegal for Americans don't go so
all of a sudden was sitting in this
village and I hear this
[Music]
so we thought the NBA was gone but we
thought we're here the POWs are dead you
know that mongers we're now behind above
five miles behind any alliance and we're
running through the village a similar
kicking this document I represent like I
kicked his pet doctor whatever it was to
get back to my helicopter the helicopter
is sinking as I parked it on a rice
paddy
I tell you Marines aren't the brightest
yeah so I had and my crew chief was a
little tiny guy kind of looked like
Woody Allen he climbs in to put in the
pilot's seat
my co-pilot and I are in the back on the
boom with this okay hit it
he starts turning the rock rudder you
know and this mud is coming up is it's
pounding us in his face and we're
rocking the damn helicopter trying to
get out of the mud and finally baguettes
in a hover the two pilots jump in we
switch sides and we take us so we I said
you stupid son of a [ __ ] while you're
your stupid son boots would fly all the
way back to the carrier and we land on
the carrier we step off covered in mud
you know and the guy said you guys don't
ask
that was my first adventure in gold and
I became a bull buck so we squeezed sail
into Hong Kong I went looking for gold
this is 73 it was still illegal for
America Sunday too it was silly little
Americans to own gold I thought that was
really strange then why is that I mean
why is that and so finally I found a
Krugerrand his Lowell store I paid 50
bucks for it I still have that
Krugerrand today it's worth about 1500
today so you know so for young guys like
you it's Bitcoin or its ethereal or
whatever you guys do for all guys like
me it's gold and silver and that's the
best the biggest difference of all so I
have millions in gold and silver kept in
another country far far away in terms of
when you think about like portfolio
construction etc right how do you think
about the gold silver and Bitcoin bucket
compared to the real estate or some of
the other investments that you've had
and obviously understanding right you
and I have a you know pretty big age gap
between us so you're optimizing for
something different
and people my age are optimizing for but
at the same time I think a lot of people
are saying well how do you think you
know Robert as a professional investor
who spent his whole life thinking about
this how do you think about that
portfolio construction given the macro
environment we're in today I don't
really think that much about I think our
needs are the same we need to have sound
money and if it's Bitcoin its sound if
it's gold and you know gold and silver
are God's money bitcoins people money
open-source you can't mess with it but
as you know the powers to be will
attempt to mess with it you know they'll
try and hack you and all this stuff
that's that's real life so the reason I
do everything I have good attorneys and
it comes you know my goal is far far
away outside this country because if
they try and confiscate it again I'm
gone so you know I just learned not to
trust my own country I hate to say that
I fought for my country I fought for my
country twice and I served I still serve
in many ways but I don't trust him if
you trust him save the dollar you know
trust in the stock market trust that CEO
who's borrowing corporate money taken
taken the corporation like GE from
triple-a the triple B buying shares
boosting their share price exiting with
stock options paying capital gains tax
versus ordinary income tax the average
person has no idea what I just said what
I'm saying is that you just got ripped
off just ripped you off then our
pensions by July electric shares put it
in the pensions and if they raise
interest rates
General Electric goes to junk it's a
whole different worlds out there but
whatever but no idea what I just said
you understand me but the average guy
doesn't that's when you just describe to
is a very circular problem right in the
sense of a lot of those stock buybacks
were fueled by debt that debt was issued
to the pension funds and therefore the
stock price was propped up by the
corporation being the
of last resort right they were the major
buyer of the stock and so all of a
sudden the second that you get companies
that now are saying wait a minute we're
not going to do stock buybacks we're not
going to issue the debt and you get into
this weird situation where what happens
the share price well if that buyer of
last resort is gone that's not good
that's probably got a fall and then you
look over at the pension sign you say
well who's holding all of that corporate
debt that looked really good week you
know two years ago four years ago now
all of a sudden I don't know if you want
to hold that a lot of it is the pensions
and so you almost get people hit twice
right they're getting hit in their
pensions but they're also then getting
hit with all the stimulus and in the
quantitative easing which just puts them
in a really really bad situation I think
well that's as you've talked about it as
the you know the corporate credit market
it's a commercial paper market or the
shank of shadow banking market so the
average mom-and-pop is watching the
stock market but the theft or the cash
heist the gross Universal cash is a
second place in the shadow banking
system and that's where all the bailouts
are going the reason I think is pretty
fishy and I know I know the criminal
virus is real but you and I knew in
September of 2019 that this that the
shadow banking system was bust people
were not showing up to buy them they
were in but they weren't showing up to
buy commercial papers you know we we
floated this not me but my friends
company floated triple-a real estate
nobody showed up to pick up the bond
there was nobody buying this stuff
that's why I'm saying Bob Iger of Disney
is now parachuting out Steve Burke of
the NBC Universal parachuting out let me
tell you something there's a reason
they're going airborne well I think it's
funny but it's sad it's tragic
yeah I've been explaining to people in
June of last year May and June of last
year I started to write a lot about the
warning signs and people literally were
writing me saying you're an idiot shut
up what do you know all this stuff and
the warning signs at first were very
easy right they were just hey
stocks are overvalued you know severely
where's all this debt going we're
probably I have to drop interest rates
at some point the economy is addicted to
stimulus right
very simple kind of structural things
but as you went through 2019 then it
became wait a minute what's going on in
the repo markets why does that seem like
every day they're having to float more
and more and more liquidity into the
market to make sure that it doesn't
seize up why are our CEO departures at
all-time highs right why why is Warren
Buffett have 12 120 billion dollars
sitting on his balance sheet
I mean you just could see all of these
little data points that suggested nobody
knows when it happens but we're close
right and then all of a sudden you get
an accelerant like the coronavirus where
to me I still it blows my mind that
people are talking about an economic
recovery when they're doing it from
their home right there looking mandated
by the government to be locked in their
home and they're talking about oh we're
gonna have a quick recovery from this it
just it just seems delusional to me it's
martial law the freedom of assembly the
right to assemble they just took that
away from us just like being PC is the
freedom of speech good I mean it's
they're taken away one by one again let
me pump my friends book here road to
ruin he talks about he says that's the
fascist state they're gonna tell you
what to do so if you don't wear that
mask you will be fined if you don't have
social distances you'll be fine
I go get a haircut you will be fine but
they're bankrupting the whole frickin
world right now this is worldwide
for what reason and again that's why I
read this book here at a free crunch of
giants they can take over our lives via
the money and that's what Griffin was
saying here in the creature from Jekyll
Island the name of the game is bailout
is to bailout the Federal Reserve Bank
that's why we're back in the 80s you
know there was Silverado savings on loan
bailed out 15 billion or something like
that who ran it Bush the same people you
know Neil Bush of George Bush faint
those guys that some of the biggest
elites as as Rickles would call their
the elites and they think they're better
than us because they mentor the best
schools and all this and but part of
yeah important this I think to that
especially in the Western world right we
get caught up to what's the Federal
Reserve doing or what's the United
States doing but this is happening all
around the world central banks around
the world are injecting liquidity
through monetary stimulus and I think
part of what gets me excited from the
Bitcoin standpoint is something like
Bitcoin is 24/7 and global so if you're
in everywhere from India to an African
country to Australia Asia wherever if
your central bank is devaluing their
currency you either want dollars or you
want something like Bitcoin once you
realize what your central bank's doing
is the same thing with the US central
bank is doing then you want the gold
silver Bitcoin etc of the world and I
think that you should end up seeing
incredible you know capital flows to
those assets as more and more people
wake up to what's happening well I you
know I think so the the biggest thing is
that I don't trust my government and and
what do you do if you don't trust your
government you can turn into what does
in talat call it's fragile and these
kids coming out of school they're so
fragile I can't believe them I mean I
say something I hurt their feelings you
know I I'm a triggering event is that
the only trigger event I know was was us
on my rifle so I have an attitude
problem you know I mean I just I just
can't take it you know if I hurt your
feelings oh my god you know what's the
real world doing to you another things
is what the hell's wrong with us what
the hell what has happened to our spirit
and that's what this book is saying is
to break the American spirit they had to
make us poor and weak and then socialism
which is ALC and Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie come in and then communism can
take it you can see it right now Boeing
is going to have to give up its self
sell some of that to the Federal Reserve
back you can see it it's centralized
government along it how long does it
take for this to play out right so we go
from capitalism socialism to communism
is that a 10-year exercise is that fifty
years what do you think it's here today
that's why I'm saying the best book was
an ran in the 50s the capitalists go
into hiding
so it's no different than my crew and I
strapped in you know and my flight of
three the gunshots take off we were
tight you know you know I'm talking
about
hmm there is no better feeling than
walking into combat with people with men
and women down with you guys we didn't
have women but men and women he trusted
with all your heart and soul people give
their lives for you that's one of my
best friend said to me you know he says
I'm alive today because dead men kept
fighting yeah he says ice I saw guys who
had just shot the [ __ ] and they just
kept fighting so he could escape and I
come back to the states and I get spit
on at Norton Air Force Base and today
most of those guys are spitting on me
became college professors or Democrats
it's a free country and you can do what
you want to do I'm not Republican or
Democrat drop this my friend but the
freedom of choice I'd rather be just
liberal I'm in-between there I mean
libertarian what are you going to call
it I just don't really want to get
involved in it so I just want to go into
hiding with my friends and I so with the
Rich Dad advisor of books you know on
taxes real estate and all this educate
yourself school teachers listen you've
been more right than wrong and on that
one I don't think you're wrong at all
because at the end of the day the system
and I say it over and over people the
system is dependent on the majority of
the population not understanding how
money works which is super super
frustrating but that is the model yep
yep yep yep and I'm you know this is a
free country you want to be a socialist
communist a PS knock yourself up but
don't impose it upon me that's all I'm
asking you know if I want to hang out
with my friends who are rich good now
people say the love of money is the root
of all the evil that's not true
it's what do you do for your money
that's evil you know if you're selling
drugs that's evil but if you're the Fed
and you're ripping people off that's
evil too if you're a school system and
you're putting kids billions of dollars
in student loans at one point seven
trillion dollars of student loan debt
every school teachers are as complicit
you know your your you're part of the
problem
get that way and by stealing the
pensions you're part of the problem
you're a complicit here's what I stab
that you'll love
small businesses in America and the
stimulus package got three hundred and
fifty billion dollars right there's one
point seven trillion dollars of student
debt so almost five times as much
student debt as we just gave to small
businesses when after the governor
Mandel a shutdown we just numbers are
stupid right I said to somebody other
today when you start talking in
trillions you have you came and write
the number most people couldn't write a
trillion if you ask them to write it
down on a piece of paper it's just such
a big number but you know I am older
this I've seen it coming for a lot
longer like I said it started in Vietnam
when I'm standing in front of this gold
vendors window behind enemy lines and I
don't even know what gold is you know I
said Marines aren't the brightest guys
thought earth but we learned quickly so
I came back and I said I don't trust my
government you know I don't trust them
they lied to us you know this guy
McNamara was Secretary of Defense he
became chairman of the World Bank after
that oh that's surprising oh my god
that's this book you're crunch yeah we
were fighting for the
military-industrial complex and today
one of the reasons those vaccines coming
out this big pharma gets rich off of it
so they're gonna make it mandatory that
we take those coronavirus which means
they get very rich don't take the virus
if you don't take the vaccine you don't
get your driver's license yeah I am I've
realized the more and more right so I
spent six and half years in the army and
met all kinds of great people and
obviously had the pleasure of going
overseas with a couple of them except
for and as I've come back what I have
realized is people that were in the
military had a crash course in
geopolitics so they got to see how other
people live in the world they got to see
the good and the bad right and when
you're walking through a country that
has suffered from socialism or communism
and you understand how did they get to
this point how did they devolve to where
they are when I'm walking through it
right now and you realize a lot of those
things are happening right now in the
United States but I think that's the
that's where people have to say I don't
understand this let me go educate myself
because a lot of those veterans have
spent time in the countries that we you
know it's easy to write off Venezuela or
Zimbabwe because we say oh that's a
third-world country their plate looks
the same thing there's no difference
between what happened there and what's
starting to happen here it's just
happened it just happens that we're
better at marketing to some degree just
remember I love this book a creature we
had to bust the American spirit and the
way you bust the American spirit was get
them sold pour they'll take the stimulus
check now I put in my tweet I'm taking
it too but I'm gonna reinvest it I'm not
gonna spend it you know I mean I'll get
richer you know what the heck I have
other friends say would you take that
check I go of course they go I'm not as
simple give me yours so righteous about
this stuff look it's not money that's
corrupt is what you do for money that
may be corrupt if you're sitting in a
job you hate that's corruption that's
anti spiritual that's fragile
ii-i've got a number of friends I don't
know where this started but one of the
one of the things that they love to say
to each other
is it's your duty to get rich because
rich means that you solve your financial
problems so you can provide safety and
protection for those you love right and
if you look at it from that standpoint
the only way to actually be successful
when it comes to money in financial
markets is to be educated and I think
that's kind of you know something you
spend last 25 plus years doing it's not
in school that's the problem and then
you must think about health wealth and
happiness the saddest thing is this is
my health care cost a fortune you know
why because insurance won't cover it so
I go to my private health care provider
a doctor I get the best health care in
the war
you know some of the stuff they put in
me is like five thousand a pop and
insurance won't cover it but you look at
Big Pharma you know they're pumping up
vaccines why don't they pump out
vaccines because they're cheap and you
don't have to test them and you can
mandate the government to pump them into
us and I suspect that's what they're
gonna do with coronavirus you know two
or three years so now that I say
everybody must take a shot of
coronavirus vaccine that's Big Pharma
getting rich they look at the food
industry they're pumping is full of
fructose and all that other sugars and
all this stuff you know little Cheerios
Cheerios on Cocoa Puffs and all this
stuff they're killing us and they're
making fortunes then the CEOs rip us off
oh my god I mean what else you know oh
my god what are we doing so that's why I
keep saying the best teachers are on
YouTube you know go listen to them even
if you disagree with them listen to what
they say that's all I'm saying open your
mind up you know cuz if you're standing
in front of a mirror right now and
you're afraid of not having enough money
and you're thinking about taking that
check you did something wrong yeah you
know the propolis between your ears and
your rock in your sub you're you're on
top of it my friend
where can where can people go find the
book the board game and everything that
you've you've got available for them to
get educators well the good news is you
know rich dad's been doing this for 25
years so I'm making fortunes the bad
news is were sold out so I mean it's
it's a good problem but we have you know
the whole purpose was this was power to
the people
a same as Bitcoin it's you know people's
money okay a cash flow board game was
designed for people to teach people and
bypass the system and we've had
thousands and thousands of thousands
cash flow clubs and different languages
people teaching people so when I said
what made your shift to Bitcoin is is we
have the same philosophy open source
people's money people's education people
teaching
bypassing a corrupt education system
that is ripping off the kids at this
moment no financial education and then
student loan debt so you know what the
kids with the lease money from the
poorest family come up even poorer from
school and my friends who have you know
they're rich their kids come out ahead
of they don't have student loan debt
they're way ahead of the game so we
screw the poor and the innocent that's
why you and I on the same team we are on
the same team you know so that's what we
have to do but we've got a bypass we
have to operate outside that system not
and not be trainers I by being a law and
the best accounts and attorneys and all
this stuff you know that pay as little
tax as possible legally but if you're an
employee you pay the highest taxes
what's brought with that picture well
yeah but the Buffett says that my
secretary pays the highest percentage of
taxes and I do so the secretary is got a
problem
yeah knoweth no vegetation yeah it's a
pretty crazy world that we're living in
all right listen I appreciate you taking
the time to do this as I said I'm a huge
fan for for many many years now and I
know a lot of people they got excited
when they saw you start tweeting a
little bit about Bitcoin and obviously
you've been at the the tip of the spear
when it comes to financial education
because I think you somehow one single
marine has replaced all of the issues in
the legacy education system and you've
done a great job so from all of us just
thank you for doing it and I want to do
this again in the future when yeah thank
you you're not bad for an army guy no
hey this was one thing I flew for the
army more than the Marine Corps well III
wasn't gonna tell you this on tape but
I'll tell you when I was in Iraq one
time one time one single time a Marine
unit called for help and we showed up
and I I've never forgotten that and I
always gave every every marine I know a
hard time I say hey listen don't don't
tell me anything about the Marines until
you go find those guys who are calling
us for help when they needed help it's a
bad the brothers as its spiritual but
people don't realize is how spiritual it
is
first word the first word at the Academy
is mission our mission it's all to serve
that's our job and we're just serving
right now so thank you for your service
absolutely all right Robert I appreciate
very much we'll talk soon
thank you